Hi everybody. So my name is John Wherry.
I'm at University of Pennsylvania, and I'm going to chair this session,
and hopefully we'll have some interesting talks to discuss.
So we're going to discuss mechanisms of immune evasion and immune
dysregulation, really focusing on different ways for the immune
response to fail or that we can
rejuvenate that immune response or anti-tumor responses.
So we're going to hear three talks on three different categories of
ways that tumors can evade and continue to grow.
The first will be from Hongbo Qi, looking at immune metabolism
and myeloid cells and dendritic cells
in the way the immune system orchestrates a response against tumors.
We're next going to hear from Long Nguyen, who's going to tell us a little bit more
from the tumor intrinsic standpoint, how tumors evolve and tumor intrinsic changes
allow for evasion. And then I'll finish out at the end talking more about the T
cell response and the way we drug exhausted T cells.
I'm not going to take any more time from the science, so I'm going to turn it over
to Hongbo to start us off.
Thanks so much John and the meeting organizer
for the great opportunity. Actually, this is my very first time to
join ACR. I was so impressed with all the science and great
way to engage with each other.
So my lab is interested in study immuno metabolism and how
we can rewire metabolism for therapeutic intervention,
especially for cancer.
To study immuno metabolism, we focus on three broad questions.
Immuno, the metabolic communication, reprogramming,
and engineering. For metabolic communication, we
consider nutrient as additional layer of
regulation for T cell responses. This goes beyond
traditional immunologic signals, T cell
receptor, costimulation, and cytokines, so therefore we call
them signal four.
Inside the cell, there's extensive metabolic rewiring
to regulate cell fate and the cell state.
And ultimately, the goal is to perturb and rewire metabolism
for therapeutic intervention. This goes for both T cells as
well the antigen-presenting cells, the dendritic cell metabolism.
Of course, the major interest of my lab is to study the tumor immune
interaction and how metabolism control this process.
For today discussion, I'd like to first give a brief overview
of our research in T cell metabolism, then I'll be
focusing mainly on the new story on dendritic cell
metabolism. As you can see, within the tumor immune landscape,
there's extensive interplay between different cells, so we decided to
take a holistic approach by looking at different component.
That's why we're interested in both T cells, dendritic cell, and the tumor cells.
To study T cell metabolism in particular, we have embraced the
power of CRISPR-based functional genomics.
We believe this is a really powerful way to reveal new biology.
It can help us discover master regulator genes,
can help us, especially through the genetic interaction screen, to rapidly
discover the causally relevant mechanistic
target.
And then by combining CRISPR screening with the single-cell RNA sequencing
and the spatial omics, we can also learn new biology.
This is to go beyond the traditional system biology
that's largely qualitative in nature, but adding on top of that
the causal perturbation, then we can derive causal
system immunology. This is true for single cell CRISPR
screen and also true for spatial CRISPR screen.
And ultimately, we can use gene editing to knock out gene or
perturb gene function for cell therapy product.
This allow us to rapidly develop therapeutic translation.
So I just can spend a few minutes to highlight a couple
of these stories, how we discover the
master regulator genes. This goes back to our very first screen.
That's when we did a number of years ago, which allow us to
identify RAG1 as a crucial, potent,
negative regulator for T cell function against tumor.
And also around similar time, we actually teamed up with John and published
two back-to-back paper,
talking about how either transcription regulation such as fly
one gene or this metabolic or nutrition sensing
pathway can be utilized by cell to regulate T cell fate.
Building upon our initial discovery of RAG1 as a
really potent negative regulator of T cell function, we
are currently working with Steven Gottschalk and Adelie in his
group, try to develop next-generation CAR T cell for solid tumor.
As we know, CAR T cells are highly effective for liquid
cancer, but for solid tumor, it
has many of their limitation. However, by
knocking out RAG1 in the B783 CAR T cells,
we show
there's markedly improved therapeutic effect.
Mechanistically, there are two different mechanism by which RAG1 knockout can
improve T cell anti-tumor effect.
The first mechanism is cell intrinsic, in that when we knockout
RAG1, the T cell upregulate the effector genes,
BTF, interferon gamma, and also at the
magnetic level from the gene cell enrichment analysis, the mitochondria
activity turn out to be the most abundantly
upregulated pathway in the absence of RAG1.
There's pioneer work from Kim-chi Ho, Greg Dougherty, and Craig
Thompson show that in the T cell exhaustion,
involved mitochondria defect. However, with RAG1 knockout, now we
can improve their metabolic and mitochondria fitness.
That's one of the major mechanism
for the RAG1 knockout CAR T cell to function
betterThe second mechanism, this is
cell-intrinsic, but the second mechanism is non-cell intrinsic, in
that RAG1 knockout CAR T cell can
rewire the tumor microenvironment.
In this case, we found this effect with adoptive transfer RAG1
knockout CAR T cell into the tumor-bearing mice.
After three weeks, either wild type or RAG1 knockout CAR T cell
disappear, but then at this time, the RAG1 knockout
CAR T cell already induced durable effect in that the tumor
microenvironment cell got changed.
So then even the endogenous T cell start to produce interferon gamma and
granzyme, and which can be further validated
by the flow cytometry. So therefore,
adoptive transfer of RAG1 knockout CAR T cell
have robust anti-tumor effect through both cell-intrinsic and also
non-cell intrinsic mechanism.
And we're also very excited to see the effect we observe with the mouse model can
be also observed in some of the
NLGS mouse model using human CAR T cell and human
cancer cell. This is true for osteosarcoma, it's true for lung
adenocarcinoma. As a matter of fact, in each of the tumor model we
examined, we essentially always see the therapeutic effect.
And this is also true for pancreatic cancer, in that Carl
June's work beautifully show the RAG1 knockout CAR T cell also
show robust anti-tumor effect against pancreatic cancer.
So currently, we're working with Steven Gottschalk and his group, and aiming to
translate the RAG1 knockout CAR T cell into clinical
trial. We're very excited by this discovery because it came from
completely unbiased screen. Now, a few years later, we're aiming
to translate into clinical trial to benefit
patients with solid tumor.
But I feel this is just the beginning.
With the CRISPR, there's so many other ways we can discover new target
and also new biology. The new biology, we believe, can be
greatly facilitated by the single-cell CRISPR screen,
such as potepsin screen. A few years ago, we showed
that this is doable using in vivo CRISPR screen at a
single-cell resolution, and we can target over
180 transcription factor, and then we can, for each genetic
perturbation, we can identify their functional effect.
So building upon this in vivo single-cell CRISPR platform, we're
currently working on the single-cell CRISPR screen of metabolic
genes. In this case, we build a library that target 200
representative metabolic enzymes.
We build that into library, transduce T cells, then
adoptive transfer a few days later, we isolate those donor-derived T
cell, then make two library. One is to capture the guide,
the other one is for single-cell RNA sequencing.
This allow us actually to make sense of all these 200 metabolic
enzyme in one shot. For example, by
calculating the perturbation effect of each of the gene in the
library, and then also by analyzing the gene program
changes, we can sort them into four buckets.
The module one through module four, this is a co-function module because these
are based on their regulatory effect upon gene deletion.
And we can group them,
some of the modules, for example, module two,
the perturbation of those modules
enrich the progenitor-exhausted T cell, Tpac cells.
And we show that for some of the different metabolic enzymes, such
as the
one-carbon metabolism, glycolysis, or trypsin metabolism, they can have
shared effect, in that they will promote the progenitor-exhausted
T cell upon
gene deletion.
On the other hand, we also found two modules, module one and the module three.
In their perturbation, they enrich the more terminal differentiated
T cells.
And here we chose two key enzymes for follow-up study,
including GCH1 and the EXT1. These are
two important enzyme for BH4 biosynthesis and
heparan sulfate biosynthesis. We found that as we
consistent with our single-cell perturbation in the individual
knockout of GCH1 and EXT1, we show the enrichment
of the exhausted
T cells at expense of the progenitor cell, in that the
LY108 T cells as well, the stemness
marker gene CD69 all got down-regulated.
And currently, we're follow-up on this observation, aiming to make sense
of how metabolic
pathway regulate T cell fate decisions in the tumor
microenvironment.
So with that quick overview, let me just switch gears by
focusing on the main discussion, today's topic.
That is on dendritic cell metabolism.
As we know, DC, especially the conventional type one dendritic cell,
those CDC1, are key mediators of CD8 T
cell immunity. Over the past few years, we have been
very interested in understanding how DC metabolism is
regulated and how that impact the functional
consequence of DC within the tumor microenvironment.
This include some of the nutrients such as lactate, lipid,
amino acid. For example, a few years ago, we showed that glutamine metabolism
is crucial for the dendritic cell in the tumor microenvironment.
As a matter of fact, actually, dendritic cell, the CDC1, the tumor cell,
they compete for glutamine, and we can actually make the tumor
microenvironment
better for therapeutic purpose by doing the intra-tumor
injection of glutamine.And for today's discussion, I would like to
focus on the mitochondrial metabolism of
CDC1 in the tumor microenvironment.
First, we performed the analysis of the heterogeneity of
CDC1 within tumor. Then we found out how this process
is dynamically regulated,
and the fate of it is today's theme, how that dysregulation of
CDC1 metabolism can be overcome by adopting the
transfer of fresh CDC1 with better
mitochondria function. And then we study the
molecular regulation of CDC1 metabolism by
focusing on mitochondria pathway.
This is project spearheaded by two really talented fellow,
Zhiyue and Ji Young in the lab.
So first, at the beginning of this project, we did a deep dive
into CDC1 within the tumor microenvironment.
We found that even though CDC1 is supposed to be
a homogeneous population, but then at the mitochondria level,
there's two different mitochondria states within CDC1 in the
tumor. There's mitochondria highest population,
which is marked by TMRM,
this is a mitochondrial membrane potential, and also the mitochondria low
population.
And this is true in many of the tumor system we examined, including
B16 over the melanoma and the lung cancer model.
And this mitochondria heterogeneity can be further
validated by SEHORS, the mitochondria activity
measurement, in that we found that compared with mitochondria
low CDC1, those mitochondria high CDC1
has better oxidative phosphorylation rate
and also has higher ATP production.
And at the image level, we see those mitochondria high cell
also show the increased mitochondrial volume, which
is imaged by the Tom20 staining.
Not only actually are those CDC1 with better
mitochondria
features shows
enhanced metabolic fitness, they also show increased
function to prime T cells. In this
in vitro culture system, we culture CDC1 with different
mitochondria activity with T cells that measure T cell
proliferation at a function readout.
You can see compared with the CDC1 with low mitochondria
fitness, those with higher mitochondria fitness shows greatly
enhanced ability to prime T cell in vivo.
So therefore, from this brief analysis, we concluded
that the intra-tumor CDC1 showed heterogeneity in their
mitochondria state with the mitochondria healthy CDC1
shows much improved activity to prime T
cells.
With this conclusion, you might ask, "So why is this process important?"
Actually, it's important because this is a highly dynamically regulated
process. We found that with the tumor progression,
the CDC1 shows a greatly
dysregulated function in their ability to prime T cells.
This is somewhat analogous to the T cell dysfunction in the tumor,
really following John's amazing pioneer work in T cells.
Here we show the DC can also undergo this functional
impairment, and this is true for both their function
as well as their mitochondria state.
In that with tumor progression, compared with tumor at
seven days, those tumor from
21 days of tumor inoculation, that CDC1
shows the
reduction of this mitochondria high population, while
at the same time they accumulate this
CDC1 with unhealthy mitochondria.
So with this observation then, we conclude that intra-tumor
CDC1 express this mitochondria dysfunction
associated with tumor progression.
And we next ask, can we overcome this functional
impairment? To test that idea,
actually, this is also true in the human cancer system.
So to test that idea, we did intra-tumor injection of CDC1.
This is basically adoptive DC therapy.
But in this case, we isolate CDC1 that's marked with
higher mitochondria activity and also compare that with total
CDC1 and also CDC1 with lower mitochondria activity.
So here the right line showed the total CDC1, their
adoptive therapy effect. And then when
we distinguish the mitochondria high with the
mitochondria low cell, you can clearly see the CDC1
with better mitochondria fitness shows greatly enhanced
ability to slow down tumor growth.
This is true
in different tumor system we look at, including the B16 ova,
MT-38, and actually a number of other tumor system.
Not only is this adoptive therapy of CDC1
with better mitochondria fitness shows enhanced
therapeutic effect, it also can act in combination with checkpoint
blockade. So in this case, with the anti-PD-L1
treatment, we can essentially completely block tumor
growth with the anti-PD-L1 blockade
together with the adoptive transfer of the
CDC1 with better mitochondria function.
And this is also true for anti-CDL4 combination therapy
as well the anti-PD-1
combination therapy. And for those mice that have
completely rejected the
tumor growth, we did a secondary reinoculation of
tumor... treatment, we found that in each of those cases, those
mice will now have the ability to completely reject
tumors, highlighting the induction of robust, durable
immunity.
So therefore, we further show that CDC1 undergo mitochondrial
dysfunction during tumor progression, and we can correct that
by adoptive transfer of CDC1 with better
mitochondria function.
In the last part, we just go into the molecular details and looking for
what's a crucial regulator of this DC
mitochondria function. And from some of our
omics analysis, for example, we compare spleen with the tumor
CDC1, we found the OP1 protein, which is a
crucial protein to make the
mitochondria fusion. And that OP1 protein is
upregulated in both our proteomic profiling.
This is also consistent with upregulation of the mitochondria
cristae formation. Mitochondria cristae is where oxidative
phosphorylation happens. This is the mitochondria fold, you can see with
the
spleen. Compared with spleen CDC1, the tumor CDC1 have
upregulation of the mitochondria cristae.
In data not shown here, but with tumor progression, this goes
actually
to decline.
To test the functional importance of OP1, we next
make the knockout of OP1. This is flux mice crossed
with C11 Cre to delete
OP1 in all dendritic cells. We found that when we
delete OP1 from DC, those DC
have impaired mitochondria cristae formation
and also marked with impaired oxidative
phosphorylation function. And also the mitochondria
state within the tumor also gets altered.
In the wild-type mice, you have this predominantly mitochondria high population,
but with OP1 knockout, this ratio gets
diminished while the mitochondria low population gets
accumulated. So therefore, OP1 deletion impaired mitochondria
morphology, function, and also their heterogeneous states in
vivo.
And to test the functional importance of this pathway, we
challenged those mice, again, with multiple tumor models, including
the transformer tumor model, p16, p53,
and lung cancer, as well as the endogenous induced, the oncogene induced,
EKT and NRAS induced
tumor lung, actually liver cancer through the hydrodynamic
injection model. And we can see that with
OP1 knockout at the recipient mice and following the
oncogene induction, they have uncontrolled tumor growth.
So therefore, OP1 was crucial for DC antitumor
function. This is largely derived from the C11 Cre system.
And to further test the CDC1 specific function of
OP1, we further used the XCR1 Cre, which
allow us to deplete OP1 in the
CDC1 specifically. Again, using mouse model, we found that
even we delete OP1 from CDC1 specifically,
those mice show impaired antitumor function.
So therefore, we conclude OP1 is a key regulator of
DC mitochondria function and also their antitumor
immunity. Of course, next question we wanted to figure
out, what's the molecular pathway by which
OP1 function within DC? To explore that
question, we used some of the omics analysis, in particular in the
ATAC-seq analysis to profile chromatin state, and
then followed by the transcription factor activity regulation.
We found NRF1, this nuclear respiration factor one,
turn out to be the number one upregulated
transcription factor activity.
Sorry, downregulated transcription factor in the absence of OP1.
And NRF1 here, not to be confused with the redox
regulation, this is the actually mitochondria respiration
factor. It's a transcription factor, the nuclear transcription factor that
regulate mitochondria function through
regulation of those many of the electron transport chain
function.
To test the function importance now of NRF1, this transcription
factor, we did two experiment. We first did the knockout
experiment through the rastergenic guided deletion system.
And on the other hand, we also did ectopic expression of
NRF1 into the OP1 knockout background.
When we first did the knockout of NRF1 in DC, we
found that as we predicted, we found the reduced basal
oxidative phosphorylation activity and also the DC
function to prime T cells is diminished.
So therefore, NRF1 deletion largely
phenocopy OP1 knockout phenotype.
On the reciprocal direction, we did ectopic
expression of NRF1 into OP1 knockout
cells. So here is the phenotype of OP1 knockout,
and upon the NRF1 overexpression, we can
partially blocked this impaired function
of OP1, and this is true for their
mitochondria function
and also true for the DC-mediated T cell priming function.
In each cases, the defect can be partially
blocked with the NRF1 overexpression.
As I alluded earlier, NRF1 is a crucial transcription factor that
regulates many of the electron transport chain expression.
Electron transport chain, there's five different complexes.
So therefore, we tested, is this pathway functionDependent
upon electron transport chain. So therefore, in this genetic rescue experiment,
we also added the drug inhibitor to block
each of this major electron transport chain,
including blocking complex one function, complex
three function, and complex five function through rotenerin,
antimycin, and oligomycin. We found that this
genetic rescue effect mediated by Nrf1 is no
longer there when we block electron transport chain expression,
suggesting that Nrf1 can support OPR-mediated
mitochondrial function in ETC, electron transport chain
flow-dependent manner.
So therefore, we concluded that Opn1 is a key regulator of
mitochondrial state of intra-tumor CDC1,
and this function through Opn1-Nrf1 signaling access and also in
an ETC flow-dependent manner. Putting everything together, we're really
excited to identify how DC can
lose their function within the tumor microenvironment.
We believe partly because that's regulated by
their mitochondrial dysfunction.
This work, just published earlier this month, is really highlighted by a
really nice review, a commentary from Malay Haldar from
UPenn,
which also highlight what I show you, this nuclear mitochondrial
bidirectional crosstalk in that Nrf1 can
regulate many of the electron transport chain expression to
regulate mitochondrial function.
On the other hand, Opn1, which a key regulator of
mitochondrial function, controls Nrf1 expression, so
therefore forming this bidirectional nuclear mitochondrial
crosstalk.
So overall, from today's discussion, by working on how metabolic
control both T cell and the dendritic cell function,
we identify key target such as Regn1 and also
new biology from the single-cell CRISPR screen.
We also identified the key regulator of DC
function in the tumor microenvironment.
And moving forward, we're really excited to continue to work on,
continue to explore this framework of how metabolism
controls the cell communication, their functional
reprogramming, and also provide opportunity for therapeutic
engineering. With that, let me just acknowledge my lab
members, Haoxi
for the single-cell CRISPR screen, Zhiyuan and Jiyan for the DC metabolism,
and also for many of our collaborator, including Steven
Gottschalk and his postdoc fellow.
It's really the collaborator that help us to engage discovery,
translation, and this technology development, and
we're really appreciative of their support and the opportunity to
us to make our discovery into therapeutics.
Thanks so much for your time. Happy to take any question you may have.
So we have time for a couple questions.
I'll just ask folks to use the microphones at the front. Lisa.
Thanks very much for the terrific data.
I'm thinking about the human translation of this, and I'm wondering
if you've had the opportunity to look at other DC subsets or other
metabolic pathways, because when we looked in humans, we found
DC2s were also defective. And when we
tried ex vivo to make good dendritic cells out of
the precursors that were already metabolically skewed, it was
glycolysis, mitochondrial OXPHOS, and glutaminolysis that were
defective. So I'm wondering how you're thinking about this broadly.
Oh, thank you so much for that question.
To compare CDC1 with other DC subset,
actually, we found CDC1 so
much metabolically active compared with CDC2.
On the other hand, this mitochondrial heterogeneity is not very
unique to DC, but also happen to other
myeloid cell. So I just feel this is such an understudied area
and also from both biology but also therapeutic
opportunity to, for example, for DC adaptive transfer, can
we isolate those DC with metabolic or mitochondrial
healthy state? And also can we rewire DC
metabolism in vivo through some, for example, the in vivo engineering
approach? I think that is really just we're just at the very beginning.
Thank you.
Over here.
Wonderful talk. It is well known that the OVA1 having
multiple protein isoforms and it's functional related, so I wonder
if you get a chance to see whether in those mitochondria high and low,
they're having different abundance of different isoforms of OVA1.
Oh, okay. Actually, in our case, we mainly look at the canonical
form from our proteomics profiling.
And, also we do a knockout, we knockout all the different
isoforms. So we haven't been able to dissect different isoform.
Thank you.
For that question.
So quick questions, so we can try to get to all four. So Rob.
Angbo, amazing talk.
My question was going to be if you have thoughts on the mechanism for how the DCs
change because of this mitochondrial rewiring and why they don't prime T-cells as
well. It seems like it was alluded to a bit in your schematic, but do they present
less antigen? Is their surface proteome different?
Right. One of the mechanism-- That's a great question, Rob.
So I think one of the mechanism we showed, I did not have time to show today is
the antigen presentation machinery.
Actually, that occur in a autophagy-dependent manner.
In this case, autophagy known to degrade the antigen
presentation machinery. That process gets dysregulated without
Opn1.
Thanks.
All right. Thank you.
Over here.
Hi. I saw that in your models you have a flank tumor
models. Do you try this approach to address its
effect in metastatic models like liver or
lung?
We have not looked at the metastatic tumor system.
All we look at the primary tumor, either transplant tumor or those
endogenous induced tumor, but we haven't looked for the
metastatic
tumor system yet.
Thank you.
Thank you for that question.
Last question, Greg?
Hongbo, great talk.
Two very
brief questions. Sorry, John.
That's okay.
One is, what are the molecular signals that repress OPA1
in the first place? What is happening in the tumor microenvironment that's actually
repressing it?
That's a great question. So I can only provide some hand-waving
answer. We found that micropinocytosis is an important
upstream signal, and that can regulate OPA1
expression. But then if you ask how is the
micropinocytosis
affected? That could be due to the nutrient deprivation, especially
when tumor progresses. But that part is
speculation.
Great, and then finally, just very briefly, if you juice up the DCs with
NRF1, do they work better as in the tumor when you do your
adoptive transfer?
Yes. We did that
experiment, but only in vitro-
Got it
... for the DC, T cell co-culture. But that's the actual next step
experiment for the adaptive DC therapy using the
NRF1 overexpress in DC.
Great. Thanks.
Or PVR gamma, your
metabolic-
Yeah. PD-1 alpha, yep.
Oh, yes.
Great. Hongbo, thank you very much.
Okay, thank you.
So our next talk is about tumor intrinsic adaptation from Long Huen
from University of Chicago.
So good afternoon, everyone. My name is Long.
I'm from the University of Chicago, and today I'm so honored to be with you
both to present about my research.
So I have no disclosure. So I work on breast cancer.
So breast cancer traditionally classified by
estrogen, progesterone or HER2 receptor.
Breast cancer is very heterogeneous, and you also have a subtype of
triple-neg breast cancer with lack of all these three marker, and
that patient with limited treatment options.
So triple-negative breast cancer account
for a portion of breast cancer, and usually it's more aggressive and more
frequent in younger women. So chemotherapy had bring some
positive outcome for triple-neg breast cancer patient in
the early setting. But however, only limited number of patient actually
can benefit for this treatment, and especially in
advanced settings, the benefit is very limited.
So as cancer biologists,
we recognize that there is a lot of driver of tumor heterogeneities,
and cancer cell is not static. It
constantly changing, and aside with genetic
alterations, it has been very clear that the stress from the tumor
microenvironment, it really play a big role in really shaping
cancer cell into this kind of high plasticity cell state that
the same exact mechanism driving these all aggressive phenotype,
like tumor cell metastasis, remodel stroma to
resistant to therapy and immune escape.
So if you zoom into the molecular level, what
actually happening is that the stress in the tumor microenvironment actually
can lower the transcriptional barrier
for cell to switch from one adaptive cell state to another.
And over time, these switching become more
frequent. It bring into cells to making become more
resistant to therapy.
So these become clear that this can be a very attractive
target for us in cancer, but however, there is a big
knowledge gap for us to understand how stress actually can
reprogram these high plasticity cell state, and how we can
leverage for therapy. So our approach in our lab is that we
try to identify new regulators
of these processes, and also define mechanism
how these cell state can escape immune system and potentially
translate to therapy. So, we
approach this by using the power of single-cell RNA-seq, because
nowadays single cell become more
powerful because it allow us to see the whole transcriptome and be able to
stratify the cancer cell intrinsic stress signals.
And doing this in various model from, syngraph
TC NBC model in human, especially in advanced settings.
So we even incubate these tumors over three
months as well as in other like mirroring TNBC model.
We see repeatedly the same things that over time, the pressure
from a tumor microenvironment can actually allow cancer
cell, when we inject clonal proliferative cell state, it allow to be able
to populating the cell state into very distinct
stress cluster from proliferative to
invasive or inflammation or to
survival under hypoxia. You can see repeat over time.
But what's surprising to us is that we see a very big
cluster of cell that actually having no distinct
features in transcriptionally, and this play around
20% to 30% of the populations. But what surprising to us is
that when you put in the 3D UMAP,
you can actually see that these types cluster, we call it transition
because it really a core of
connecting all the kind of stressed cell state together.
And this not reflect just transcriptionally through 3D UMAP.
We can see it in spatial. You can see that it's really connecting within all
these kind of stressed cell state very elegantly.
So before coming too far, I want to walk back a little bit to ask whether
all of these cell state I described are clinically relevant.
So using breast cancer cell, single-cell RNA-seq, and look
across patient, we can see-The supply heterogeneities
across patients. But what's surprising here, you can see here in
some patients, these transitions, they play a big portion in
these patients. Next, when looking into
I-SPY clinical trial result, which is for advanced high-risk
triple-negative breast cancer patient, and using genes HRO on this cell state and
lay out from top to bottom, using genes HRO on this cell state,
you can see that the switch from a better
outcome to likely to non-responder is happening exactly in
this transition state. And using artificial intelligence and machine learning
through collaboration at UChicago and to predict that at FPE,
how it correlate with TILs in patients from both Yale and UChicago clinical
trial cohort, we can see very clear that the exactly
transition states into HRO really predict
T-cell exclusion in patients. So it really point to us
that potential this genes program actually play a big role
in T-cell exclusion in breast cancer.
And so the next question, what are the key regulator of transcriptional
program of this state transition?
So, using DNA binding motif and look at
the motif of all the gene expression, the signature on the
cluster, and lay out from proliferative to stress response, you can see
that,
not surprising, many of these
factor predict to regulate this kind of cluster are related to
linear stem factor like SOCS or OX.
But many of these
have been known to regulate immune invasion in various cancer.
But the problem is that we cannot target them because it's essential for
development. But what bring us to attention is that they are
a cluster of stress factor. I want to bring attention to
BACH1 predict to a top regulator
of this transition state. So what is BACH1?
Is that there are a lot of
mistake between BACH1 and B, which is BTB and CNC
homolog 1. So these are very different with BRCA1
binding proteins. So BACH1 itself, canonically, they act as
transcription repressor. They can bind to merhaba binding motif
and counteract with NRF2 to regulate redox biology
in cells.
But
in the stress conditions, BACH1 can be able to compete with
AP1 binding motif to be able to promote a lot
of genes to relate to metastasis, and it have been shown that BACH1 can
be a master regulator of metastasis process across cancer.
So how BACH1 potentially regulate this transcriptional
plasticity is that
if I lay out on the cells to the zero time, and
using hypoxic gradient, as you can see here, you can see the transcriptome
as a whole really transform from low hypoxic genes to
more extreme hypoxia. There's a change
drastically. So what BACH1 do is that when you knock out BACH1, you can see a
really drastic change in plasticity of how the gene
relate to this transition state are formed across the gradient.
You can see they change the plasticity.
And because of that, when you over-expression BACH1, you can be able to
increase more population of this cell state.
So,
next, what we do is that we're using genes HRO that we've built by using
multiple in vivo over-expression and knockout using spin knockout in
spatial to build BACH1 genes HROs and come
back to patient to ask how BACH1 activity correlate with outcome.
And what is striking to us is that BACH1 activity really predicts
BCR or respond rate in TNBC in a pembro and
chemo arm. And more importantly, across cohort, we
can see the very beautiful negative correlation between BACH1 and TILs,
especially in the advanced settings.
And using the same strategy I described earlier, you can see that across
cohort from trial from Yale and UChicago, you can see the
beautiful correlation between TILs and BACH1 activities.
That bring us to the next question, is that whether cancer cell intrinsic BACH1
can try immune invasion in TNBC. So when we do the
experiment, we want to look in... Mostly on our experiment, we look into
advanced stage, so we really incubate tumor over a very long period of
time. Here is over six weeks, and you can see that after
six weeks, what is striking for us is that BACH1 knockout can really
increase amount of CD8 T cell infiltrate into a tumor, and we'll be able to
rescue this phenotype by put back BACH1.
And not only just more infiltration, these cell really reflect more proliferative
features or more activation features.
And also that really reflect into the tumor growth.
So at beginning, you can see a reduction in tumor growth, but
eventually BACH1 knockout tumor, eventually it's coming back.
But that really translate to a more drastic reduction in lung
metastasis. And all of these changes we don't observe in
nude mice, suggest that adaptive immunity play
important roles. We also further see that there is very
early T-cell activation in tumor-draining lymph nodes.
So we can see that through transcription and through flow cytometry across time
point. So what is the mechanism by which can the cell intrinsic
BACH1 drive immune invasion in TNBC?
So I can answer to you that there is various mechanism, but today I
want to tell one. So, using single-cell RNA-seq, we'll be
able to see that across the tumor compartment, you can
see that there is increase of type I interferon
response across tumor compartment, and this really align with
the cytokine
screening. We also see that interferon phi is among the top that
really induced by BACH1 knockout.
And what is exciting for us is that BACH1 and the transcription
repressor, they bind directly to the IP21 interferon
locus.To be able to potentially repress these
signalings. And using spatial, and we'll be able to look
at cell-cell interactions and see that what is this
internal pathway to connect to each other.
We can see that a PIK signaling from cancer
cell to the tumor microenvironment.
And that, along with the data that when we inject mice with interferon
alpha receptor to block, we could be able to potentially rescue some
part of the phenotype of what BACH1 cancer cell intrinsic to
the lymph node. For example, here you can partially rescue some of the
activation of CDA and changing in CD4.
And also changing in the recruitment of pro-inflammatory myeloid
compartment or DC cells to lymph nodes.
So how we translate this? So we tie it back on to enhance immunotherapy
response. So our approach to do this is that we, if you
recall earlier tumor growth is that initially we can have
some benefit in reduction of tumor growth, but eventually the tumor coming back
suggests some compensation. So in our lab, we're looking
through this mechanism by look at the late state tumors and
ask what is the cell-cell interaction really work together, and
what is striking for us here is that you can see the very
drastic increase of CDA and CTL for signaling came from a TRAC to the
CDA compartment in the 41 tumor in a BACH1 knockout.
And we further divided it by flow cytometry show that
at early time point, you can see some benefit of BACH1 knockout to TRAC compartment
and increase this ratio from CDA to TRAC.
But eventually, this
benefit become lost over time by the increase of TRACs.
And because of that, when BACH1 knockout when combined with
anti-CTLA-4 in this model, it worked really well to embed
the tumor control.
And so how we translate this to patients?
That's a very important question.
So, come back to a little bit to the literature is that
BACH1 as a transcription factor is one of the few transcription
factor be able to bind to Heme. So what they do is that they be able to bind
to Heme and export to cytosolics and promote
decorations. And using a single cell in lymph node to
model this, we'll be able to come up with a strategy that short core
of Heme in treatment, we'll be able to model,
we make a BACH1 knockout to activating T cells in lymph node
early on. And with the same strategy, we'll be able to have a
better tumor control.
So the highlight of my study is that we identify BACH1 as the one novel
cancer cell intrinsic
target that driving immune evasion in breast cancer, and we can
using genetics and pharmacologic strategy to
target BACH1. And I forgot to mention that Heme have FDA approved
versions that our clinical fellow here potentially bring it
to clinical trial. That very exciting.
And we also can identify BACH1 as a new
predictive biomarker immunotherapy response.
And if you recall recently, the parallel of
BACH1 and BACH2, which is also another homolog of
BACH1, that really a driving stamina of T
cell in the tumor microenvironment.
This is very beautiful parallel of BACH1 as another
stress sensor mechanism, a BACH factor to driving immune invasion.
So future direction, there is a lot of avenue for us to do it.
For example, optimize this treatment strategy to clinical next.
The second further, visiting mechanism and conversation mechanism for BACH1
targeting. And if you recall, we identify these type
stress cell state is not rare, it not rare stem cell, but it really prominent
in tumor in advanced state. We'll be able to look at other
potential transcriptional target as well as
surface marker to be effectively target this
pathway. And last but not least, I would love to thank you, the
support from my PI and also all our collaborator at U Chicago,
and also patient advocate, Katie Baker here.
And, last but not least, Susan G. Komen Career Transition Award that have been very
supportive for my research. Thank you so much. Yeah.
Great talk. We have time for a few questions.
So I wanted to start, actually. I'm wondering if the type I
interferon targeting can explain the whole phenotype.
Explain the whole thing. Yeah.
Yeah.
It partially only. Yeah.
So there is definitely a lot of more mechanism.
I think,
one of big part is BACH1 can really reprogram the oxygen gradients in a
tumor microenvironment, and that is something we are following right now. Yeah.
And then do you know if BACH1 binds other genomic
locations?
Yeah.
And is there any role for repressing endogenous retroelements which would drive the
type I interferon?
You ask on point. Yeah. That is exactly one of the project we're
working on, and we investigate on that.
I think as a repressor, that is one of the thing. Yeah.
Yeah.
Great. A question over here.
Hi. So there's a session that present
yesterday that he say that by regulating the Heme expression, he
can prevent the CDA T cell exhausted
version, and then maintain the effector function of CDA.
So because you also mentioned that you can regulate the BACH1 knockout-
Yes
... as using the Heme, did you take a look on the
exhaustion state of the CD8 T cell in your BACH1 knockout?
Exhaustion of T cells?
Yes.
Yeah. I
show a flow symmetry. You can see that,
BACH1 have a more activated T cell, but eventually, when you do a single cell in
late state, it become exhausted. Yeah.
So you also can see that they also increase exhaustion. Yeah. Later.
Great. Rob?
Great talk.
Thank you.
What do you think the interferon is doing?
Why do you think you're getting a resistance phenotype because of interferon?
I think that interferon will increasing more CDA T cell and at
beginning in the tumor, partially we rescue that.
And I think that-Driving the more inflammatory
features in the tumors. And I think that eventually you can have more
TREG, and that drive the resistance.
Yeah.
Partially, I think.
One suggestion, you guys could follow that up by figuring out whether it's
tumor-intrinsic interferon or interferon that other cells are sensing by
just doing-
Yes. That is exactly what we are following to this. Yeah.
My second real quick question is, do you get
a resistance phenotype if you further overexpress it?
So do you get a continuous phenotype where loss of function increases
sensitivity, and then overexpression increases resistance in the models that you
use?
I think we only be able to overexpress in the knockout to see
it rescue, but we never do overexpression
in the wild type to see it further enhanced.
So that is a very good suggestion to do it. Yeah.
Good job.
Thank you so much. Yeah.
Hi. Here you showed that hypoxia was the
driver that's inducing this BACH1 increase.
Yeah.
Have you looked at any other cell, different stress
conditions to see if it mimics that?
Yes. I do believe that a lot of stressors can induce BACH1.
We do know that hypoxia can induce BACH1 very well in the
HIF-independent manner. And, there is definitely a
lot of
other stressors, for example, low glucose-
Mm-hmm
... also can potentially induce BACH1.
There is many other follow-up paper that using
metabolite under hypoxia can potentially modulate protein
to induce BACH1, too. And,
as you know that low iron
also
play a big part in stabilizing BACH1 protein. Yeah.
Last question.
Hi. This is Dr. Pal from Boston Children's Hospital.
Thank you.
So as we know that BACH1 is the negative
regulator of stress-regulated proteins, and
NRF2 is the positive regulator.
Right.
So, in your system, have you seen any correlation
between BACH1 versus NRF2?
I think this is one of the biggest question in the redox field, and I
think it's context dependent. I think it's dependent on cell line
and also system that there is a balance between NRF2 and BACH1,
depend on the state that they have expressed.
What we do know is that, in a more chronic stress state,
NRF2 really activate to allow cell to survival, but I think
BACH1 play a very important role in term of making decisions,
whether they can go to survival mode or
migrations. And I think that is really a hotspot of switching
and fate decision.
And you ask the right question. I think,
doing this a lot, I feel like it really context dependent.
There is some
system that can see that they positively regulate together, but
also there is other system that they actually counteract each other.
But what
I do know is that they're constantly competing.
And, when NRF2 is overexpressed, they actually
can
kick out BACH1 out of MEF2 sequence, which is canonical
repressing DNA binding motif-
Mm-hmm
... and also force them to go to AP1 motif to compete with
AP1, and that is where the BACH1 become switching into
promoting gene expressions instead of repressed gene expression.
And we do know that the mechanism is partially through
chromatin remodelings in the AP1 hotspot, which is important for
adaptations in multiple cancer. Yeah.
And also the last question is, in your experiments, so did you do
the experiments in the hypoxic condition or in the normoxic
condition?
Yeah, because one of the big question for us is that,
understand BACH1 regulation by hypoxia,
so we do both. So more importantly is that we don't just do
acute hypoxia, but we also expose cell to
chronic hypoxia to see the function of BACH1 in
cancer cell intrinsic mechanism.
And what I can answer to you is that the chronic exposure to hypoxia is so
important, where the stress factor really show the big role.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Great. Thank you.
Okay. So,
I'm John Wherry. I'm going to round this out with the last talk.
I'm going to talk today about how we've been thinking about drugging the PD-1
pathway. I'm going to tell you about work we've been doing for actually some
time on the immunopharmacology of anti-PD-1 therapy and what
different ways of thinking about drugging PD-1 do to exhausted T cells.
So a few disclosures. None of them are really relevant for today's talk.
But I'm going to do three things. I'm going to very briefly at the beginning tell
you a little bit about exhausted T cells as the target of PD-1 therapy.
This is a little bit like bringing coals to Newcastle, I guess, for this audience.
But I just want to frame the discussion for what I'm going to show in the second
two parts, which is some of our recent work on understanding the
effect of,
fittingly, chronic stress on exhausted progenitor cells and what that
does to their biology, and then how we're thinking about drugging or overcoming
some of that long-term stress in the exhausted T cell pool.
So I was with Jim Allison a few weeks ago, and he pointed out that
the number of people who have been cured or
are alive today because of checkpoint blockade probably is now approaching a
million people.
These drugs have been an absolute breakthrough since the first reports of human
treatment in around 2012. And of course, we now
know that the major target of PD-1 blockade are
exhausted T cells, probably in lymphoid tissue, but also in the
tumor microenvironment. CTLA-4 probably works on early T cells as they're getting
activated, whereas PD-1 works a little bit later.
And so we've been really trying to understand the biology of exhausted T cells and
how they respond to PD-1 blockade so we can improve these therapies for those
people who haven't benefited so far.I like to always start with this
slide because I think there's some features of exhausted T cells that require some
sort of level setting and sort of some benchmarking.
I'm just showing you a very simple example of a memory T cell or an exhausted T
cell that we get from the mouse model of LCMV infection.
These T cells are responding to the same peptide of the virus.
They're present at the same frequency in this flow plot.
The memory T cells can simultaneously produce interferon and TNF.
Exhausted T cells do this very poorly.
I want to point out, though, that these cells are not functionally inert.
Exhausted T cells actually do make a low level of interfering gamma, and you can
see it there in this flow plot. They're probably very important
locally for managing effector function at a low level.
Now, their evolutionary origin probably did not include
responding to cancer. That's sort of a post-reproductive age problem.
But these cells are probably critically important for managing chronic infections,
things like herpes viruses, things like polyomaviruses, and setting up
a host pathogen stalemate that's functional for the host to survive through
reproduction.
But importantly, these exhausted T cells end up in disease settings where we'd
rather have a memory T cell. They actually have a poor recall response when you
stimulate them. They don't divide very much in response to new antigen, although,
as I'll mention along the way, they're chronically undergoing activation and
division.
Unlike memory T cells that respond to homeostatic cytokines, IL-7 and
IL-15, for their stem cell-like maintenance, exhausted T cells become
addicted to TCR signaling. So TCR signaling is what drives them to
become exhausted, and yet the cells can't live without it after some period of
time. If you take away TCR signaling, the vast majority of exhausted T cells
die and disappear from the host. Now, of course, we're interested in these cells
because when you block the PD-1 pathway, we do regain some effector function from
exhausted T cells, and that is what mediates our anti-tumor effect
in humans. Memory T cells are, by
comparison, relatively unresponsive to PD-1 blockade.
Even when they get activated and upregulate PD-1, blocking PD-1 for those
cells doesn't matter too much. We know a lot about the biology of what makes
exhausted T cells and their epigenetic programming by a transcription factor called
Tox that sort of writes their epigenetic landscape to be
completely different from effector or memory T cells.
So we think about the development of exhausted T cells in sort of a differentiation
scheme, where after some period of activation and differentiation for
the first one or two weeks, cells make a fate choice, and they either go down a
path to become memory and effector cells or a path to become exhausted T
cells. We know that epigenetically, these exhausted T cells at the
bottom are about as different, in terms of open chromatin landscape,
from the ones at the top as B cells are for macrophages.
So drugging exhausted T cells really requires that we understand the
biology of these cells. Now, once this population of cells is formed,
there's a nice sort of proliferative hierarchy that develops down here that I'm
going to talk about on the next slide.
But I just want to mention that to get to this point of having exhausted T cells,
including those stem-like progenitor cells that we all see and are interested
in in lymphoid tissue, usually takes one to two weeks.
So the things that happen before that, really the cells are still fate flexible.
And an important point that I always like to make is many of these cells on
the left-hand side here express many of the markers associated with T
cell exhaustion. They express PD-1. They're highly activated.
They express TIM-3, LAG-3, and other checkpoints as effector
cells. And so it's important to know that there's sort of a temporal aspect to
developing exhaustion, and some of the ways we think about this may
require us to make sure we're looking at truly exhausted T cells.
So the reason we're interested in this is because when you block the PD-1 pathway,
what happens is you end up targeting these progenitor cells that are sort of the
root of the proliferative hierarchy. These cells are PD-1 positive.
They express Tox. They also express the transcription factor TCF-1.
And in response to chronic antigen stimulation, these cells are
constantly ticking over, dividing, and differentiating into the more
terminal populations downstream.
Now, the reason that we care about all of this is because when you block the PD-1
pathway, what you're doing is releasing this brake that keeps the whole system sort
of tempered and balanced, and you shift things from the left
to the right, and that shift is associated with partial, and I'll show you
temporary, regain of effector function.
Okay. So one of the things we wanted to know a long time ago was to ask
what happens if exhausted T cells are overstimulated, if they get stimulated
too long or the stimulation strength increases.
And so we did this experiment, which I think was informative at the time,
and that was we genetically removed PD-1 from
cells that were going to become exhausted.
It was tricky to do in this model. I won't belabor the details.
This is an old paper, and you can look it up.
But the bottom line is getting rid of PD-1, where the entire mouse is
wild type, but only the responding T cells are PD-1 knockout.
There's tremendous benefit early.
This is exactly the biology that we and others have published on PD-1 blockade.
But what was interesting, when you let this go over time, these cells continue to
erode, and over time, they do far worse than wild
type cells that still have PD-1. At the end of this experiment, they're less
functional per cell. They're not proliferating as much.
And this is due to increased TCR signaling, and the cells
eventually burn out and disappear.
Carl June has seen the same thing in an example of PD-1 knockout CAR T
cells in humans, where the PD-1 knockout CAR T cells actually competed
less well over time than the PD-1 wild type CAR T cells.
So if that's true and long-term loss of PD-1 is detrimental to the
durability of these cells, why are we blocking PD-1 in our patients
essentially indefinitely? And so most of our clinical regimens for PD-1 blockade
involve blocking PD-1 for a year, sometimes two years, or until
progression. And so we wanted to start to ask the question of
what happens when you block this pathway long term, and is that the best
strategy for drugging the PD-1 pathway?
So we sort of posed to ourself a question.
So what if we wanted to block PD-1 in different ways, sort of different temporal
regimens to manipulating this pathway?
So there were a bunch of challenges to thinking about these experiments.
The first was that most mouse tumor models are progressive.They're changing
in size over time. They grow very quickly, most of them, and makes it very
difficult to compare apples to oranges.
If you block early, say, and then come back and block again later, you now have
tumors of different sizes, and the mice are progressing.
So we needed a model that reached some sort of pseudo-equilibrium, as I'll mention
in a minute.
We don't get that in most animal models.
Most patients come in in a pseudo-equilibrium where the tumor's been at some
steady state interaction for some period of time.
The worst and most embarrassing problem for all of us is that
most of us are using rat antibodies in mice, where we
know that you get anti-drug antibodies within about 12 to 15 days.
And so anything you do after that, you're actually not doing the experiment you
think you are because these antibodies are neutralizing.
And then finally, it's very, very difficult to address this question of doing
a washout study in humans because most of our anti-PD-1 drugs
in humans have been modeled on nivolumab or pembrolizumab.
And at least for nivo, the cell surface bound half-life-- Now, the serum
half-life of any of these antibodies is about three weeks, but the cell surface
bound half-life of nivo is six months after a single
injection. So it's very difficult to get to a point where there's no more drug on
board and ask what happens now if you re-treat.
So Xin in the lab, a fantastic postdoc, wanted to ask this question using the
LCMV model and a mouse anti mouse PD-1 antibody.
Wanted to ask what the best regimen was, and we wanted to compare a single cycle,
so essentially two weeks of treatment, which is roughly equivalent to one dose
in humans, where we get sort of exposure to the drug for three weeks.
Long-term treatment in mice for three months
or an intermittent, or we end up calling a drug holiday, where we treat for
two weeks, do a two-month washout, and we know during that time the drug is
gone, and then re-treat again for two months.
So let me first show you the comparison of just what we're calling a single cycle
or short-term versus long-term PD-1 blockade.
And in this setting, we're treating for two weeks in chronic LCMV infection, then
we let the mice go for another two and a half months, or we treat for three months
continuously, and we ask if there's any benefit for long-term treatment.
This is the experimental design just up at the top.
This is the flow cytometry, but the data is right here.
So when you block the PD-1 pathway, you get a burst of reinvigoration,
and then in this case, after short-term treatment, that reinvigoration goes away
and the cells return back to some baseline, both quantitatively and qualitatively.
If you block continuously, the shape of the curve is essentially identical.
And while there's this P value here for the frequency, the absolute numbers are not
different between these groups, at this day 56 time point.
And at the end, they end up in exactly the same place.
So the shape of that curve really kind of bothered me because it's exactly the
shape of the curve we see in humans.
When you look at reinvigoration of T cells in human melanoma patients or lung
cancer patients or the list goes on, you essentially get one peak of immune
reinvigoration in the peripheral blood.
We don't know in the tumor exactly, but it looks very much like the mouse
experiments, despite the fact that these humans are continually treated with
anti-PD-1 antibodies. This is true for a large number of patients.
This is about 28 patients we've looked at here, but we've looked at many others
since then.
So we wanted to ask, what would happen if we actually gave the T cells a break?
Treat for two weeks, then do a drug washout, and then come back and
re-treat.
So in this experiment I'm going to show you, we had two controls.
One is blocking the PD-1 pathway short-term early and then letting them
go. But we also wanted to know maybe the disease is changing over time, so we did a
short-term blockade, just at the end, the last two weeks.
But the data are very clear. When you block the PD-1 pathway just one time at the
beginning, you see the curve that I showed you the last time, the solid circles
here. But if you do a washout and then come back and re-treat, you
see tremendous reinvigoration, and that reinvigoration the second
time is of a similar magnitude if these mice are getting anti
PD-1 for the first time. So a drug holiday
allows these exhausted T cells to mount another round of immune
reinvigoration. This results in a better T cell response
quantitatively. I'm just showing you one part of this.
This is true throughout many tissues.
And in fact, you get better control of disease in this animal model of
chronic viral infection.
I'll just say in passing, we have used tumor models where we can treat mice for
longer periods of time. We can't do a drug washout very easily there, but long-term
treatment in tumor models is not any better than the short-term treatment.
But this drug holiday is now giving us better disease control.
So I want to return to this schematic, this sort of proliferative hierarchy, where
we have these progenitor cells and then they differentiate into downstream cells.
What I didn't point out on the previous slide is that most of the clinical benefit
or
disease control that we get in animal models or clinical benefit in humans comes
from this intermediate population.
This intermediate population is the one that arises from proliferation of those
progenitor cells, but it regains effector function, at least temporarily,
as it's differentiating towards terminal exhaustion.
And so we wanted to understand how these different treatment regimens specifically
were affecting this intermediate population.
And we can see those cells, many of you probably know this, in mice using
Ly108 to see the progenitor cells, CD63CR1 to see the
intermediate cells, or lack of both molecules is actually our
terminal cells. So what happens with our drug
holiday versus long-term treatment?
And very clearly, in the control, we have these intermediate cells arising from
the steady state differentiation of progenitor cells.
Our drug holiday preserves that population.
But long-term treatment almost completely erodes the presence of those
exhausted intermediate cells that actually have a little bit better effector
function.
So a key feature of those TPECs cells, or those stem-like cells, in the
exhausted pool is to withstand and adapt to chronic stress of stimulation.
So we wanted to understand when we remove PD-1, a negative regulator of TCR
signaling or co-stimulation, how does prolonged loss of the
PD-1 pathway change those abilities of those progenitor cells?
So we did a simple experiment. It's at least simple on paper.
It's not that easy to do, nor is it that easy to explain.
But we took mice that had been exposed to PD-1 blockade long
termWe took out their progenitor cells.
We mixed them one to one with progenitor cells isolated from
congenitally distinct mice that were infection matched.
So we're now comparing head to head untreated progenitor cells with progenitor
cells that have been treated for three months with anti-PD-1.
We put them back into infection matched mice, back into the same environment they
came from, and blocked the PD-1 pathway.
The question was: are those long-term treated progenitor
cells different from their untreated controls?
And the answer is again, pretty black and white.
In those untreated control progenitor cells, when you block the PD-1 pathway, you
get a huge population of those exhausted intermediate cells.
This is what gives you the clinical benefit from PD-1 blockade.
But in those progenitor cells that have been treated long-term with anti-PD-1,
this ability to generate those exhausted intermediate cells is severely
compromised. And in fact, you see a bias to getting more of the terminally
exhausted cells in this setting.
So what you have, just take a simple schematic here.
These progenitor cells often give rise to the intermediate cells.
These cells are heterogeneous but also have more effector function, and eventually
many of those cells go on to become terminally exhausted over time.
There may be another pathway where you can go straight to the terminal population.
And in fact, when we treat long-term with PD-1 blockade, we seem to be
inducing or propagating a shunt that avoids these more
effector-like intermediate exhausted T cells.
So we did a lot of work. I don't have time to tell you about a lot of the details,
but a lot of transcriptional profiling, looking only at those progenitor exhausted
T cells. These UMAPs are focused only on those progenitor or Tpex
cells, and they're very different transcriptionally.
And I'm just going to highlight
the way the UMAP looks up here, and it's really focused just on one cluster, this
cluster zero. And there's a lot of interesting biology here.
There's a lot of stress response biology, but one molecule caught our attention
in these overstimulated Tpex cells, and that's
CD22. It's caught our attention for a couple reasons.
One, very clearly the protein is pretty highly expressed, but only on the
progenitor exhausted T cells. And two, any of you who do
work on B cells might know that this is a really potent negative
regulatory molecule on B cells. And in fact, CD22 plays a role on
germinal center B cells in negatively regulating BCR signaling.
It has four items, four in humans, three in
mice. It negatively regulates signaling through SHIP1,
GRB2, SHIP. It binds sialic acids
in cis or in trans. It can bind itself, and it's a pretty potent negative
regulator of B cell differentiation, B cell signaling.
So what was it doing on progenitor exhausted T cells?
Well, we've learned over the years of almost 30 years of doing transcriptional
profiling of T cells now that when you see a B cell gene in your T cells, it's
probably not because the sort was messy. It's probably real biology.
It's how we and others first found Blimp1 in T cells and so
on. So we wanted to ask, what would happen if we targeted this molecule?
So we used an experimental design that we thought was going to be very difficult.
We took these mice that have been treated long-term with PD-1 blockade, and we
simply added on a blocking antibody to CD22.
And for those of you that have been doing this a long time, this is the place where
all drugs fail. When patients progress on PD-1 and we add on another checkpoint,
this is extremely difficult to get responses there.
In fact, LAG-3 is a good example where the first trial with LAG-3 in
humans was to take PD-1 progressers in melanoma and add on LAG-3.
Clinical response rates there were around 11% to 13% when
BMS finally put that therapy up front.
So primary treatment with PD-1 and LAG-3, you saw about a 39% or 40% clinical
response rate. So this is a very high bar to see if we could get a response in this
setting. But indeed, when we did this, we saw that there was a major boost
in reinvigorating those exhausted T cells. So this is pre-therapy.
The groups are pretty similar. In fact, the group that's going to get
anti-CD22 may be a tad lower, but actually they do
much better afterwards. And in fact, that results in control
of systemic viral replication by adding on a blocking antibody to
CD22 late.
So we did a lot of things here. We looked early in primary treatment
early. I'm not going to show you that data in the interest of time.
We also did experiments in B cell depleted mice that said that at least part of
this response, probably most of this effect, is not dependent on B cells.
I can't exclude a role for B cells, but B cell depletion in this model is
complicated because you change the entire lymphoid environment.
What we wanted to do to sort of avoid some of those things was ask what would
happen if we co-targeted PD-1 and CD22 together.
So we built a bispecific antibody where one arm targets CD22,
one arm targets PD-1, and just ask, this is now sort of primary
treatment. How does a bispecific targeting PD-1 and
CD22 compare to single arm molecules targeting CD22
or PD-1 separately?
In fact, when we do this, we see a remarkable response of the bispecific in
reinvigorating the T cells. So numerically, there are way more T cells by frequency
or number in multiple tissues. We see that these T cells
are proliferating more. They're also more functional.
I'm not showing you that data, but we get more interferon, more interferon
TNF co-production, and we control disease
substantially better than either of the single R molecules
that we see here.
So looks like targeting PD-1 and CD22 is
beneficial, and it's beneficial by targeting these Tpex populations.
LCMV is a great model. It's the first place where we saw real responses to
PD-1 checkpoint blockade in reinvigorating exhausted T cells.
It's told us a lot about the biology of exhausted T cells, but there are clear
differences with tumor models. We wanted to ask whether we see the same
biology, and I'm just going to show you one example of a tumor model in mice.
This is the AT3 ova model, where we're using a flank version of the
AT3 tumor model. In the TILS themselves, we put in
OT1 cells so we could track tumor specific T cells.
In this case,
there's a little bit of CD22, but really not much.
Most of what we see for the tumor specific T cells is actually in the tumor
draining lymphAnd we think this is important because we think this is where these
more robust progenitor cells are living, in lymphoid tissue, in the lymphoid
environments that actually allow them to interact with the proper dendritic cells.
And so we wanted to ask then, what would happen in this AT3 model
if we blocked both PD-1 and CD22?
So we set this up again, AT3 OVA flank model.
We're not putting in OT1s here. We wanted to sort of make this as difficult as
possible. And I'll just point out the timing here.
So we're actually waiting quite late in this model.
It's very difficult to actually get an effective therapy when we wait this long
with AT3. In fact, you'll see that our PD-1
only doesn't have a great effect here.
But when we block with the bispecific antibody, we see considerable tumor
control. We also see that we increase the number of T cells in the tumor,
and especially the number of T cells that look like exhausted T cells infiltrating
the tumor. We're working on this in a number of other tumor models, and there are a
bunch more questions that we want to ask here about the role of
CD22, especially in TLS environments and in the lymphoid
tissue.
So let me just summarize quickly and then leave a few minutes for questions.
So the first
point I want to make, and summary point,
is that we've started to think about the molecules we inject
to induce immunotherapy responses as
prodrugs. They're not targeting the disease cells themselves.
And in fact, the mechanism by which we achieve an effect on disease
is through the changed T cell. So the T cell is really the drug.
The anti-PD-1 is the prodrug. We think this is important because if we want to
understand how our drug is working, we need to be studying the
biology and indeed the pharmacokinetics and pharmacodynamics of that in
vivo drug.
Prolonged loss of PD-1 signals is not always an advantage for these cells.
We see very clearly we're eroding this Tpex biology by
chronically removing the PD-1 pathway. This makes perfect sense.
These cells have adapted to reach an equilibrium of
signaling with the disease, and the T cell.
And if you change that equilibrium and increase the signal strength, it will have
an effect on the cells. There's a nice paper from Ron Germain looking early in the
response suggesting, in fact, PD-1 is used to tune that system.
A drug holiday allows for sufficient rest for these cells to mount a
new reinvigoration response. This is, in many ways, T cell
biology 101. For T cells to remain fit, they need rest from
stimulation. We've learned this through prime boost vaccines, we've learned this
through lots of other things. And so by removing PD-1 blockade
for some period of time and allowing the system to reset, we get another round of
immune reinvigoration, which gives us additional clinical benefit in
this mouse model.
By studying the pharmacodynamic effects of this drug holiday and long-term
treatment, we were able to reveal other pathways that are useful targets.
Now, whether CD22 is going to be a blockbuster clinical drug, I don't know.
But the key point is that by studying that stress
response, the adaptation that occurs, we can reveal pathways and
opportunities to change the biology in ways that we can't if we are not
studying that pharmacodynamic effect.
And I'll just end by saying that we think it's very important to think about how we
drug the dynamics of the immune system.
We published a paper last year or a year and a half ago with Andy Minn, where
we looked at temporal changes in the way we drug interferon responses
that are similar to thinking about temporal ways that we can drug the PD-1 pathway
and TCR signaling.
So I'm going to end here. I mentioned Xin did almost all of this work.
We had
great collaboration with Dave Weiner and Ryan O'Connell helped us with the
bispecific antibody. I mentioned some of the early work that we did,
was done by Sean Blackburn, Michael Paley, two previous students in the lab, and
Alex Hwang, a former fellow in the lab who did a lot of the clinical melanoma work.
Stop there, and happy to take questions.
Great talk. Thank you very much. Eben Rosenthal, Vanderbilt.
So do you think this could be a dose modulation effect?
In other words, are we giving too high a dose, or is
the drug holiday maybe affected
in a more long-term way if we just don't give as much?
Yeah. It's a great question. Alan Korman was here somewhere and
may be the better person to answer that.
In the original studies, only some of which are in the public domain for
nivo,
there really wasn't a clear dose cutoff.
You got pretty effective blockade of the PD-1 pathway, even with about a 5 to
10 or tenfold lower dose.
In those early studies, there was a conclusion, I think the data was reasonable,
that you only need about 60% receptor occupancy for full biological
effect. So I don't know if we can dose down, especially if the off rate of the
antibody is so slow.
It seems to be recycled and seems to be present
very long term. It's a great question.
I think it'd be great to have drugs that hit the receptor in different ways.
My analogy is we're hitting the receptor as just basically an on/off switch.
There are lots of other pathways that we drug pharmacologically where we use
nuanced sort of rheostats for those pathways. We don't have them here yet.
Yeah.
Amazing talk. So when you have
the chronic overstimulation of CD8 T cells
with anti-PD-1, you have overstimulation and probably some
apoptosis in CD8 T cells, and that's maybe why you don't
see the intermediate exhausted. Then you have upregulation of
CD22. If you block CD22, then you will have
even more stimulation because that's a repressor, right?
So how come that works?
Yes. Yeah, great question. I'm so glad you asked this because it is a really
important point. So most of these kind of things will be very
useful, but temporarily, right? And so
we've only done one thing that seems to change the epigenetics
of exhausted T cells, and it has to do with STAT5 activation.
I don't think these drugs are really changing the epigenetics of who these cells
are. So what we're trying to do is sort of get waves of new cells coming out.
You're right, they will be short-term.
And if we ask for thatThat bolus of cells to be
continually propagated, we're going to lose.
But if we can drug the dynamics so we can get waves of new cells, we should be able
to do this over and over again. You're right, the cells we get will be short-term,
and we think that these CD22 provoked cells will also be
short-term and will die off. If we could keep them alive longer, we would.
And actually, the STAT5 drugging seems to keep them alive longer, not with
CD22, but with PD-1. So it's a great question. I think you're exactly right.
Yeah, Eric?
Great talk, John. Two questions. The first one, do you see this
population of CD22
in humans? First question, obvious question, sorry about that.
The second one,
do you know whether there are some ligands of CD22 which are very
important for what you are describing?
Yeah, both great questions. So we've been looking in humans, and it's a reason why
I made the point about the tumor-draining lymph node versus the tumor.
When we look in tumor, we can see them, but it's like the tumor in mouse,
very, very few CD22 positive cells.
But these are tumors that don't have very much TLS structure, head, neck, and
melanoma.
We are trying to get our hands on tumor-draining lymph nodes to see if we can see
more there. When we look in the public
RNAseq databases, we can see them, but they're pretty rare.
So jury's still out on how abundant they will be in humans.
But I'd love to get tumor-draining lymph nodes to look at this more if we could.
In terms of ligand, CD22 is a ligand of itself.
It's also buying sialic acids on typically APCs
for the germinal center B cells. Probably large molecules like
CD43, CD45 with their sialic acids.
We haven't looked at that very carefully yet, but that's the next question.
Yeah, Eric.
Beautiful story.
When you were doing your two monoclonals independently, so PD-1 and then
CD22,
would you say that was more of a model of adaptive resistance?
Yeah, we think about this as adaptive resistance.
When you're blocking PD-1 long-term,
the populations of cells have adapted to a new proliferative
hierarchy that is no longer responsive to PD-1 blockade.
That is a form of adaptive resistance that's sort of T cell intrinsic, and we can
overcome that with CD22 blockade.
Okay, thanks.
Yeah. Thanks.
Yeah.
Hi. Great talk. I have a question. So when
you say there is a drug holiday,
so what if the cancer is more aggressive and the T cells are
getting a lot of antigenic stimulation and the TPECs
have already become TX? So how does the
second dose of the drug work in that situation?
Yeah. So there are two questions embedded there.
One is, of course, if tumors are progressing, you may not want to stop therapy.
It's a very difficult kind of ethical question and clinical question.
I recognize that, and we don't have a good answer for that yet.
When you have high antigen burden, in most cases, there are always
these TPEC cells there. You can think about this developmental biology
exactly the same as any other tissue, including the hematopoietic system.
Even when you have lymphopenia,
your HSCs are still making more cells.
Just because there's been stress on the system, it doesn't mean that the HSCs, or
in this case, the TPECs, go away entirely.
What often happens when you stress that system is you take away the more activated
stem cells and you preserve the more quiescent stem cells.
And this is, in fact, what you see in a lot of tissues where you're trying to
preserve the clone of the stem cell, which I think fits here.
So we think that's what's happening.
We don't seem to burn out those TPECs 100% in most
cases. So maybe in the interest of time, we'll take one more question each, and
then I'm happy to stay after.
Great talk. Gabe Starbuck Miller, VMS.
I guess
what your talk is suggesting to me, it's the shorter half-life PD-1
engagers or multi-specifics. That may be of interest to
help enforce this sort of holiday scenario.
So do you believe that the PD-1 VEGF out there, although they're doing many other
things, one thing that's happening is the half-lives are a week or something
like that. Do you believe or think your data is suggesting that some of the
benefits of those designs actually has this sort of drug holiday
scenario incorporated?
I was so hoping someone wouldn't ask me about the PD-1 VEGFs.
I have no idea how they're working, and if somebody does, I'd love an answer.
That's as plausible as many of the other things I've heard, and it would be really
interesting if we could study it. I like that idea.
I haven't seen any data to support it yet.
Great. Thanks.
Yeah, thanks. Yeah.
Thanks. Very inspiring talk. Since you mentioned all these treatments that don't
really rewrite the epigenetic code of the T cells, what do you think of
a way to do that? Like you mentioned, these are tox regulated.
Is there any way we can manipulate tox to doing something with that?
Yeah. It's a great question. We've been very interested in this for more than a
decade now. Getting rid of tox is not the answer because tox is also
essential for survival of these cells. So if you get rid of tox, the cells all die.
And so tox is very complicated. The only thing that we've done
over the past decade or so that seems to change the epigenetics, at least
partially, is actually enforcing STAT5 signals,
whether through
better IL-2s, ortho IL-2, or constituively active STAT5.
We published that paper a year or two ago.
None of the epigenetic regulators, when we delete them, what we do is we
actually just change the amount of cells going through a transition state.
I mean, very much like Long talked about, just any transition state in
developmental biology, that seems to be where the epigenetic regulators work.
We haven't fully reprogrammed the epigenetics very substantially yet.
So it's a really important area for future work.
Thank you.
Great. Thank you. Thanks, everybody, and I want to thank the other two speakers for
a great session.
Thanks for being here.